it's checking some work but I finally
have them the worst of the worst
we're let's just say I put them in the
hole two away the hole whose rumors men
know that some of them have abilities oh
yeah I have seen things maybe Superman
was some kind of beacon for them to
creep back from the shadows
I want to assemble a task force of the
most dangerous people on the planet who
I think can do some good
they're bad guys exactly and if anything
goes wrong we blame them we have
built-in deniability what makes you
think you can control because getting
people to act against their own
self-interest is what I do follow him
I use the devil all you need to know is
you work for me
so that's it huh when it passes
with some kind of Suicide Squad
so save the world
earrings
you got insurance
now they say about the crazy ones huh oh
I'm not gonna kill ya
I'm just gonna hurt you
really really
hey everybody is Charlie there's a lot
of big stuff happening right now so I
just I wanted to get this out as quick
as possible so that's why you're not
seeing my face right now
but lots of stuff to talk about new
Suicide Squad coming new Wonder Woman
new Batman V Superman so all kinds of
footage gonna be dropping really soon so
what's going on so the flash arrow and
legends of tomorrow are all coming back
starting on the 19th the flash episode
10 right after that they're airing two
back-to-back half-hour specials the
first one is gonna be for legends of
tomorrow it's gonna be like DC doing
their version of emergency awesome of
like the stuff that I do they're like
hey everybody there's this new amazing
thing that you have to check out now you
guys know about legends of tomorrow
because I won't shut up about it but
obviously not everybody that watches TV
watches YouTube videos so they're a lot
a lot of people that price they'll have
no idea what's going on with legends of
tomorrow right after that they're doing
a Batman vs Superman Suicide Squad
special where they're gonna air a brand
new trailer and new footage from the
Wonder Woman movie so it's like an
entire week of television that DC is
gonna own it's gonna be so awesome now I
think the legends of tomorrow special is
just gonna be its own self-contained
thing Kevin Smith and Jeff Jones are
gonna host the the Batman V Superman
Suicide Squad movie part of that but
they're both like two separate half hour
specials they're like boat you know both
their own little thing it'll air right
after the flash episode 10 finishes I'll
have to figure out how I'm gonna do my
videos for that because I'll have a
flash video they're not Suicide Squad
then a Batman V Superman and a Wonder
Woman video I'll figure it out don't
worry but what's gonna happen is is in
like the next couple of weeks as we get
ready for that I'll just be doing more
Suicide Squad more Batman V Superman
probably some Deadpool stuff because
that's coming in February along with all
the other normal flash arrow Marvel
stuff that's happening it's gonna be the
biggest January we've had in a long time
like last she was actually pretty quiet
they there was agent Carter and flash
and arrow came back at the end of the
month but now it's like that on steroids
now I can hear a lot of you guys raising
your hand on the background you're like
hey wait a minute
isn't Marvel doing a Captain America
75th anniversary special on January 19th
that's the same day that DC is doing its
specials yes that is right I will
totally do a video for that Captain
America stuff too I'm kind of expecting
them to drop new footage from Civil War
and I know a lot of you think that
there's like a Thor leaked clip there is
no leaked thor ragnarok clip so so don't
don't worry about that
like they barely even started making
that movie
it's just a combination of deleted
scenes from Thor the dark world and
Avengers age of Ultron but yes Hulk will
be in Thor Ragnarok just answer that
question so what's happening now is I'm
still kind of playing catch-up cuz I'm
on my way home from my vacation so I
have daredevil Punisher coming later
then I'll do some new Suicide Squad
stuff cuz I haven't done a video for
that in a long time
Nance and new legends of tomorrow so be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway this week all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but I just I can't wait to see
Geoff Johns and Kevin Smith start like
adult crying on television as they get
excited for all this stuff you know it
would be really awesome if Kevin Smith
were to get Geoff Johns and Mark Waid to
come on comic book men and they just had
like a comic book trivia episode of all
the people working in comics right now I
don't think that anybody knows more
about comic book history than Mark Waid
and Geoff Johns like Geoff Johns job
like one of his big jobs at DC is to
kind of oversee creative on all the
films and all the TV shows and all that
stuff eat you know the whole comic book
line but he also puts together big
binders of explainers like the kind of
explainer videos that i make he puts
those together for studio executives to
explain characters when they're working
on new movies like who is this character
we're talking about putting in the
Justice League movie here's the giant
binder explaining them so if any of you
guys are personal friends with Mark Waid
and Geoff Johns see if you can subtly
haze them into doing like a comic book
trivia a TV show that would be amazing
and fun bit of trivia in case you're not
a comic book reader Mark Waid is the
person who wrote the flash comic the
Wally West flash comic for a long time
before a Grant Morrison came on and then
Geoff Johns came on and did his
revolutionary flash rebirth arc and kind
of revitalized the entire flash line so
Mark Waid and Geoff Johns are just like
two of the biggest people to ever write
the flash comic ever why gigas wait for
daredevil new Suicide Squad all that
stuff to post you can click here for the
Batman V Superman video that I posted
last night and you can click here for
the new flash killer frost trailer that
I just posted thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys a little bit
Oh